.
>> Jason: MATT FINN,
THANK YOU.
SADLY, RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
CONTINUE TO MOCK THE SPEED TENDE
DIPLOMACY
IT COMES AS THE COACH SAYS THERE
IS STANDARDS OF PLAY ARE GIVING
IF IT'S LeBRON JAMES
IMPRISONED OVERSEAS, HE'D BE
ALREADY BACK HOME.
BUCK SEXTON AND CLAY TRAVIS,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LET'S START WITH YOU.
WOULD YOU MAKE OF THE STORY?
>> I THINK THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD AT PLAY.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US ON.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD IS THAT IF
DONALD TRUMP WERE PRESIDENT,
HE'D ALREADY HAVE BRITTANY
GREINER BACK.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE UCLA
BASKETBALL PLAYERS WHO WERE
ARRESTED IN CHINA, TRUMP GOT
PERSONALLY INVOLVED.
TRUMP GOT PERSONALLY INVOLVED
AND WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE WAR IN
EUROPE AT ALL, I DON'T THINK
RUSSIA WOULD HAVE INVADED
UKRAINE IF TRUMP WERE PRESIDENT,
BUT IF THIS HAD HAPPEN
REGARDLESS, I THINK TRUMP WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN INVOLVED AND GOTTEN
BRITTANY GREINER BACK.
IF BRITTANY GREINER HAS REGRETS,
IT'S POTENTIALLY TRAVELING WITH
DRUGS IN RUSSIA WHICH SHE
REGRETTED IN LETTER, VOTING FOR
JOE BIDEN.
>> YEAH, I THINK DONALD TRUMP
WAS ABLE TO BRING BACK 55
PRISONERS.
MIKE POMPEO INVOLVED WITH THOSE.
TRUMP BROUGHT HOME 55 DETAINEES
AROUND THE WORLD.
HE KNEW HOW TO GET IT DONE.
>> WE HAVE TO ADD FOREIGN POLICY
AND CLOSE ON THE FOREIGN STAGE
OF JUST UNDER FAILURES TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
JOE BIDEN WAS BROUGHT ONTO THE
OBAMA PRESIDENTIAL TICKET TO THE
FOREIGN POLICY GUY AND IF YOU
REMEMBER THAT EIGHT YEARS -- I
KNOW YOU DO, OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THERE WAS A
FOREIGN POLICY DISASTER.
NOTHING SURPRISING ABOUT
JOE BIDEN BEING INCAPABLE OF
NEGOTIATING A DEAL TO GET --
DON'T GET THIS WRONG, I WANT
EVERY AMERICAN HOME, THE OTHER
AMERICANS INCLUDING PAUL WEYLAND
HOME FROM RUSSIA.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T HAVE WHAT IT TAKES TO
NEGOTIATE THE DEAL.
THE PERSONAL GRAVITAS THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS.
RUSSIA KNOWS THIS WHICH IS BY
THE WAY, THERE IS A RUMOR
FLOATING AROUND THAT MAY BE THAT
GUYS LORD OF WAR NICOLAS CAGE
PLAYED THE ARMS DEALER.
THAT MAY BE THE TRADE THAT'S
OFFERED HERE.
THERE'S A GUY KNOWN AS THE
MERCHANT MAY BE TRADING FOR
BRITTNEY GRINER REPORTED BY
FORBES EARLIER TODAY.
THAT WOULD BE QUITE A MOVE AND
FROM THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
WOULD IT BE SURPRISING?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Jason: CLAY, THERE IS AN
AURA OF INCOMPETENCE THAT
PERMEATES THROUGHOUT.
YOU'VE GOT STAFF KIND OF DIVING
FOR THE EXIT.
IT'S SAD TO WATCH AND DO YOU
EVEN HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE ACTIVE
DEMOCRATS BEING QUOTED AND
TALKED ABOUT IN POLITICO AND
OTHER PUBLICATIONS SAYING THE
GUY'S.
>> I THINK IT'S TELLING, WE WERE
TALKING ON THE RADIO SHOW
EARLIER TODAY.
BARACK OBAMA DIDN'T ENDORSE
JOE BIDEN UNTIL HE HAD ALREADY
WRAPPED UP THE NOMINATION.
IT SHOWS IN 2016 TO EXPRESSLY
PASS BY HIS VICE PRESIDENT AND
INSTEAD ENDORSE
HILLARY CLINTON'S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
NOT JUST AN AURA OF
INCOMPETENCE, IT IS
INCOMPETENCE.
HE'S THE WORST AMERICAN
PRESIDENT SO FAR IN 100 YEARS
AND WHEN ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE UPSET ABOUT MEAN TWEETS AND
TOLD US THEY HAD TO BE ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY, GUESS
WHAT.
THEY VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN AND
DEFINITIVELY ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF HISTORY WHETHER IT'S FOREIGN
POLICY, THE BORDER, CRIME,
INFLATION, EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT JOE BIDEN TOUCHES TURNS TO.
IT'S THE ABSOLUTE OPPOSITE OF
THE MIDAS TOUCH.
>> Jason: WHEN THE GUY HAS
NEARLY 50 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE,
HE DIDN'T JUST SUDDENLY
SURPRISED PEOPLE IN THE LAST 18
MONTHS.
THEY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE
GETTING, AND NOW THEY'RE HAVING
TO LIVE WITH IT.
>> CLAY SAID IT WELL.
YOU LOOK AT ALL THE AREAS OF
FAILURE, YOU NEVER HAVE THE TIME
TO REALLY WORK THROUGH THEM ALL
ON ANY SHOW INCLUDING OUR OWN.
YOU CAN FIND YOURSELF JUST
TALKING ABOUT NOT ONLY THE
PROMISES THAT WERE NOT KEPT.
IT JOE BIDEN'S AND HE WAS GOING
TO REUNIFY THE COUNTRY.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T WANT TO GET THE MANDATORY
VACCINE LIKE THEY ARE SOME KIND
OF TERRORIST GROUP.
JOE BIDEN FAILED CONSISTENTLY ON
EVERYTHING THAT HE HAS TOUCHED
BUT LET'S REMEMBER DEMOCRATS,
UNTIL 5 MINUTES AGO, KNEW THIS
GUY WAS SUB-MEDIOCRITY AND A
LOSER.
NEVER REALLY TAKEN SERIOUSLY AS
A CANDIDATE, BUT IN THE PANDEMIC
YEAR WHEN AMERICA WAS BEING TOLD
BASICALLY WE'RE ALL GOING TO
DIE, IT WAS ALL TRUMP'S FAULT,
WE NEEDED A GRANDFATHERLY FEED
THE OUTCOME OF THE MEDIA PLAYED
THIS WHOLE THING OUT, AND NOW
WE'VE GOT THE EXACT CANDIDATE TO
COME AT THE TROJAN HORSE FOR THE
LEFT, THE INCOMPETENT BUFFOON
THAT WE WEREN'T AMERICA OUT,
THEY DID, I DID, YOU DID